[Music]
all right before we go I have one more
holiday themed story to share this is
what I'm liking
[Music]
I love the unique
you need to celebrate Christmas no doubt
that applies to a grandmother from New
Jersey Crystal and Somerdale has one of
the largest collections of black Santa
Clauses in the country she started
collecting black Santa's nearly 30 years
ago and since then it's filled up her
entire home let's get her in here
everybody say hello to Crystal what's up
Krista
okay hello so you have a very good
reason for loving Christmas so much
right yes I do my birthday's on
Christmas Eve so how can I not love
Christmas I love well I don't know I
know a lot of people would have to share
that holiday and they don't like it they
get trumped but I love your optimism
about it so can you show us a few of
your favorites sure I have a couple I
have the first one I received from my
late husband this was the first one
very special to me I love that though so
you're so did your late husband actually
get you into this like starting the
collection yeah the first one started we
just moved into our home and we said we
weren't buying Christmas gifts for each
other we got the house we were out
shopping and I saw this and it was the
first time I've ever seen a Santa Claus
of color
so I was I was a leader in the store we
left the store I didn't buy it but he
surprised me and he gave it to me for my
birthday which was Christmas Eve so it
worked out well I love that I love how
it started as well well it's an awesome
collection thank you so much Crystal for
sharing with us I'm liking your post
right now
thank you all right well that's not all
our Susan long partner pilot pin makers
of friction the go-to erasable pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate people like you who share the
joy and magic of the holiday spirit so
they're going to give you a thousand
dollars just for being cool
oh
thank you thank you
uh Chris still have such a great
holidays thank you so much Kristen thank
you to all our guests our Brendan Fraser
Sadie Singh Grinch and our very own
grumpy elf it's not having a great day
y'all try and change it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]